krishell stouse is opening up about why
she and jason oppenheim split after five
months of dating the selling sunset star
wrote this three-page post addressing
the breakup according to her statement
it seems she wanted to start a family
and that was a deal breaker for jason
quote jason was and is my best friend
and other than our ideas for a family
ultimately not being aligned the amount
of respect and love we have for each
other will not change going forward men
have the luxury of time that women don't
and that's just the way it goes
but krishele is remaining positive about
her future writing quote i very much
hope to one day have a family and
decisions i make at this point are with
that goal in mind so i'm just keeping an
open mind and to no surprise her girls
have her back krishell's co-stars and
good friends mary fitzgerald amanza
smith and emma hernan all sent her love
in the comments section this is our girl
she's our friend
we protect her krishele's statement came
after jason confirmed the split on his
instagram the real estate broker shared
similar sentiments to his now ex writing
quote while we have different wants
regarding a family we continue to have
the utmost respect for one another
adding having her in my life is one of
the best things that has ever happened
to me this is the most kind of
fulfilling and rewarding relationship
i've ever been in
and it looks like jason isn't the only
newly single openheim brother just hours
after news of his split came to light
jason's brother brett revealed he's also
no longer in a relationship with his
girlfriend tina louise he made the
confession during an instagram q a about
real estate this question has absolutely
nothing to do with real estate but i
will answer it um
as of very recently actually yes
but back to gracel and jason we have
just just such deep trust and respect
that i just it doesn't if there's one
person on the planet i think i'd be
comfortable
putting my relationship out there with
on camera it's hurt the pair first
confirmed their romance over the summer
sharing these pda filled vacation photos
to instagram and the breakup news comes
shortly after their relationship became
on-screen official and a sneak peek for
season five of the hit reality series
did you guys hear the news
no less news
it's insane to me i don't know what to
say i knew before they told me so weird
though but like exciting but like so
right i'm not getting into that you know
we're not criminals we're not doing
anything wrong
[Music]
i've never had a situation happen before
where i became best friends with someone
first
and it's just been so kind of freeing
i'm my complete whole self good bad and
different whatever and it's it's the
best way to do it because we knew
everything about each other we worked so
well together we have so much respect
for each other
so i think that that is a really good
formula to start a relationship
[Music]
you